here I have a simple example of an app
built with knockout this example was
built by Ryan niemeyer and you can find
the link to it in the instructor notes
in this app we have a button and a
number that updates when you press the
button if you click the button too many
times it notifies you and lets you reset
with a different button now rather than
show you the example code here I'm going
to copy all of this into sublime text
now I'm not going to pay any attention
to the CSS in this example just the
JavaScript and the HTML here I'm also
going to change this to say click rather
than click me that way we can see this
entire line let's pay special attention
to the HTML in this example the counter
is a span with a data attribute on it
now the buttons and the notification
area all have data bind attributes to
and it's those data bind attributes that
connect up the view with the rest of the
application knockout reads these and
starts watching the buttons and updating
the views now let's go through these one
by one our counter here says data bind
equals text number of clicks so let's
remember that name right there if we
look at the JavaScript you'll find
number of clicks is actually AKO
observable now we don't quite know what
that means yet we'll talk about that in
the next lesson but the point is that's
the way things are connecting up the
data bind attribute here is the way we
tell knock out that we always want that
span to show the value of number of
clicks whenever number of clicks here
changes knockout will change the view
automatically now let's look at the
click me button here its data bind
attribute says click register click
disable has clicked too many times it's
important to notice the comma right
there this and this are two separate
bindings what these bindings are saying
are if the user clicks on this button
run the register click function over in
the view model and disable the button
when has clicked too many times is true
and sure enough if we pop over here well
see that register clicks is indeed a
method on the view model and will also
notice that this stuff has clicked too
many times is something to this is a KO
computed and that we're also going to
talk about in the future don't worry
about it too much if we hop back to the
HTML let's see if you can guess what
this and this do